we start with a couple of breaking  issues on the road and just an absolute  mess this is a live look at the  Northbound Lanes on I-15 near Tropicana  you can see that white stuff on the road  there there's a truck blocking the  highway as you can see the Northbound  lanes are blocked traffic is jammed back  to at least Spring Mountain we're not  exactly sure what caused that spill but  you can see the debris there and all the  work that's going on is a big presence  but there are other cameras that show  the traffic backed all the way up on  I-15 towards Sahara it's an absolute  mess so if you're leaving your house  right now to head on Northbound I-15  this is near Tropicana again find  another way